welcome back to the gentleman sitting to
my right spent seven seasons as a cast
member of Saturday Night Live and he's
got a new series called single parents
it's on after Modern Family on the last
Wednesday of this month September 26th
at 9:30 p.m. Eastern Time and then a
couple days later in theaters near you
with Kevin Hart in night school good to
see you Taryn Kaitlyn thank you for
having me my friend now I need to
describe for the radio audience what I'm
sure it's looking in when I physique or
know what I'm wearing so I've got I've
got a starters jacket yes sir from the
John Robinson arrow Los Angeles Rams yes
I believe I see a new era cap this is
correct of a Rams logo trucker style
adjustable which is yep with classic
classic navy and gold Rams helmet on the
front and side on the side exactly on
the far side then the t-shirt that says
girly hungry on it yeah and on the back
it says feed the girly and yes this is a
custom-made shirt from custom Inc calm
and original kill'em creation so you are
you are just out of your mind right now
you have to be out of your money it's
pretty it's a pretty exciting time and
and last night was sort of a perfect
game to start for multiple reasons the
short answer is because we won by 20
points and it was wonderful and Marcus
Peters got to prove himself at the end
and then grab his nether regions and
he's got to get fine for that right is
that how is that well I think it yes
because I think he he he pawed the hole
he did you know took the full handfuls
you know a skosh unless when you do eggs
and bacon it's really then you're on the
50k it's so exciting
but I also loved that it was the two
former LA teams playing yesterday in
Oakland Stadium the last sort of you
know we're in we're in the final
countdown of them getting the
opportunity to cheer for their team
before they go
to Vegas and just literally become a
criminal organization great way to
describe the race and and and I am IIIi
am an unapologetic Marshawn Lynch fan I
love him I think he's just a phenomenal
athlete
I think he's hilarious and brilliant and
to see him come out last night with that
energy
carrying carrying five defensive players
across the goal line well it was just it
was just good football it was just fun
good football and the energy the stadium
was great and it was and then you know
my team won but certainly by end of
third quarter fourth quarter it was kind
of like okay this is it you're in a
rocking chair at that point in time and
whatever concerns you had in the first
half whatever thinks needed to be worked
out because Sean McVeigh decided plate
nobody in the preseason I know that was
that was gone by the wayside by the
middle of the third and fourth quarter
yes the thing that I we talked about at
the top of the show here Chris and I
taran killam
is that we love and they may come back
to bite and burn later on love second
down you need a burn clock we're gonna
throw it deep yeah third down yes you
know you don't want to give it back but
guess what you're gonna we're gonna run
our plays mm-hmm and it's aggressive
it's in your face it's exciting you know
it was the it was the screen pass play
that really kind of brought them to life
like I feel like that was their sort of
Frankenstein lightning bolt where
they're like alright we're using we're
using the screen but you could tell that
their mission statement in the game was
we want to honor cooks we want to show
cooks ability his speed and and they
targeted him more than any other
receiver I believe and he finally
finally started connecting towards the
end I still don't think we've seen the
full potential of all of all the
acquirements in the offseason of all the
trades
I think cooks has the potential to make
the biggest difference because Watkins
is a great player
but he was at best a distraction you
know what I mean he was like kind of at
best just a scarecrow to draw players
are away from woods and from Cup and I
think still we'll see a lot of activity
as we did last night from woods in Cup
but I think cooks could really become
that deep threat I think Cup and you're
too
I mean I know if I spa lished as he
looks and again it's just one week we
didn't even know Donald's name get call
I know but if but but like if you go
back and you watch cuz Aaron's my
favorite player on the team I love them
all and they're all my babies and
children and I want them to lead
fruitful happy lives and find somebody
who loves them you know what I mean I
want them to find their soul mate but
Aaron Donald I just I just his his work
ethic his talent his size his speed and
if you watch the game know he didn't
have the Marcus Peters moment even da
McCann had like you know a few tackles
and I don't know that Aaron ended up
with a tackle in the game but he was
always within three feet of that
quarterback almost every play car hurt
him there's no question yeah car hurt
yes yes taran killam here on the Rich
Eisen show I mean this is just a a-hole
Rams hootenanny right now it's so
exciting so exciting we're in we're in
Los Angeles
it's yeah I'm a Los Angeles native I
grew up here I was born in Culver City
and then lived in the South Bay then
moved to Big Bear and then back to the
South Bay at 16 and I've been here ever
since except for when I went to New York
for SNL and I've loved football my whole
life and always wanted a team you know I
was I was more into the Raiders when it
was Marcus Allen Bo Jackson how he you
know that was a great team that was
exciting but at 18 or 19 I said the
first team we get back I'm all in on and
I looked like he was gonna be the
Jaguars for a while there for a couple
seasons it was gonna be the Jaguars and
I was like and when it end up being the
the Rams it just it felt right and it
was exciting and now we have the Carson
City Chargers as well so Carson City
Chargers the Triple C I love it cubed CQ
so now I'm sure there are some fans
sitting out there and home watching this
or listening to us right now Terrence a
so you didn't you didn't travel to st.
Louis you know yeah I mean like I you
got to you got to skip that whole saying
I'm the greatest show on turf you didn't
I know okay so that's good I mean that's
at least
[ __ ] like if you didn't hop on the
bandwagon when Warner and no hawk were
doing it I loved his story I loved that
he was bagging groceries and then became
a Super Bowl champ I loved it and I've
been in I've been an NFL fan my whole
adult life from like my teens and and
fantasy is what really sort of you know
plunged me into the depths of it okay
but I just it didn't feel right claiming
a team not from my hometown not for my
turf and and you know LA has a
reputation of fair weather we also I
think the biggest challenge of being a
sports fan in Los Angeles is half of the
population are from other cities come
from our transplants right so you know
that very first preseason against the
Cowboys where they broke attendance
records at the Coliseum and almost
filled up a stadium that can hold a
hundred thousand it was you know I'm I'm
being polite to my team if I say 70%
Cowboys fans Rams fans it's just a very
exciting opportunity for me because
football just just like sort of in a
nostalgic way for me it's very much my
Citizen Kane rosebud growing up football
games Super Bowl Sunday parties chips
and dip family together grown-ups
watching the game kids running around in
the living room it's this really great
sort of a warm missed out about
community about tribe that's what I'm
most excited about with this team is if
you watch any of the postgame locker
room stuff you see Marcus Peters with
like tears in his eyes this guy who has
a reputation of like not being a team
player of being having huge ego be
having an attitude in the locker room
saying you've made you've welcomed me
you made me feel like I'm part of a
family I'm proud to be a ram with like
tears and you go well that's that's how
they're gonna get to the Superbowl that
you know you can have all the talent in
the world but if you don't have cohesion
then and I think that's what McVeigh I
think that's his gift is cohesion is
inspiring you know that the we before me
nobody's ever Chris you've been here
every single day we're celebrating our
fourth year next month before your
anniversary congratulations anybody I Q
is anybody ever drawn a line from
Citizen Kane to Marcus has anybody done
that no
is that the first time just running back
through the anybody ever made a rosebud
reference wearing a girlie hungry --oh
self-made t-shirt is that ever happen
got it I think that's the first yeah
first so whatever Ben were there have
been any team that moved to LA that
would give you the sake you know what
I'm gonna still just play fantasy
football
no I whoever was coming back rounds I
was gonna go all around I'd go for the
Browns and I got hard knocks is so good
right it was great yes he's such a good
I could just broke my heart practice
squad
you should practice squad just for his
dad just for the crystals just for the
energy I love that I love that dynamic
juice was awesome of just you know like
you know misogynistic agro alpha male
testosterone and and this is just a
centered beautiful delicate human being
who's you know built like a Goliath so
meditating and rubbing when we loved the
offensive line coach Bob Wiley who looks
like oh my yeah he looks like Wilford
Brimley oh my god Tigers old paddy I had
a baby with Craig Stadler and added 100
pounds exercise basically for the
stretch of band when they were storming
the beaches would celebrity or slot
actors actresses when they allow a hard
knocks would they allow that behind the
scenes of a movie you show what's the
environment you would do that in you
know I'm a night school hard knock hard
night school knocks yeah yeah see
Tiffany Haddish just literally like
clean the halls with Kevin Hart for
instance Kevin Hart has been a comedian
for the last 15 years but he's about to
meet his match I don't know if you saw
when I left SNL they were airing hard
knocks and I just on a whim started
filming footage of me cleaning out my
office and I knew I had a mutual friend
with Liev and I so I emailed him and I
said hey I took all this footage I have
like a script in my mind is there any
way that Liam would record these two
paragraphs for me an email I sent that
out 8:00 p.m. yes by 6:00 a.m. the next
morning was in my inbox and it's great
and so there's this little thing it's on
Instagram but my favorite part of it and
my buddy Derek waters who's the host and
creator of Jennifer Street we laugh
about this all the time
is we have didn't clearly didn't know
who I am and that's fine because he goes
Taran Killam has been a cast member on
Saturday Night Live for six seasons it's
perfect it's perfect for somebody like
leaving a job starting an unknown
chapter just a tauren kill him well
people everybody knows the name torrent
Taran Killam you're on the Rich Eisen
show a couple more minutes left it's
watching the double dip on Monday Night
Football last night it was just one
commercial for single parents after
thanks man yeah congratulations on this
it's on after Modern Family which is a
great spot yes yes Brad Garrett on the
show who is as really known as they come
for this so beloved like in the little
press we've already done for single
parents people are just excited to see
Brad and he's hilarious on the show and
Leighton Meester from Gossip Girl is
another co-star and is just the
loveliest coolest we'll be friends for
forever already you know no matter what
happens with the show but I'm proud of
the show I think it's a good show I
think it's a funny show I think you know
we have the spot the the network seems
to believe in it but more than anything
it's a show with real heart you know
it's it's the sentimental stuff that I'm
most excited about for people to see I
mean real heart you with Kevin and then
just real hard you know when Kevin Hart
gets thrown back from the barbeque store
and crashes into the windshield of his
Porsche it always brings a tear to my
eye in the night school night school
again is on September 28th two days
after single parents debuts on ABC we
just showed a clip to the TV audience of
you sharing over sharing with a bunch of
other
yes yes school where you are this scene
takes place yes and it reminded me of
when my oldest who's now 10 went through
his first school experience with his
preschool and the teacher would keep all
the parents afterwards for a circle-time
conversation for parents to just share
their experiences I love it and and in
the way you over shared in the scene we
just saw some people would over share in
similar fashion it was so awkward and I
always thought to myself I will never
ever say a word like this ever which is
kind of a jerk even if they came away
like I was I was not going to share I
told him about my emotional breakdown
doing laundry and he didn't even fight
smile actually the only the only time I
did share this is funny is that I sat
there and listened to a parent talk
about how they just could not potty
train their child and they were just
really concerned that they were not
going to potty train this job mm-hmm and
then just listening to her she revealed
it was their fourth kid so they've been
through it yeah this is my first and she
made me think to myself like what the
hell like why i listening to you
complaints so I just raised my hand I'm
like don't worry about it
I only have one kid but I've just peed
myself right now
and I'm I'm 42 years old and I just felt
so good rich here now on timeout please
face the corner and for the macaroni
necklace of shame single parents is on
ABC after Modern Family Wednesday nights
at 9:30 p.m. Eastern Time
we're gonna take a break thanks for
coming on for the radio audience but for
the audience we're gonna show a clip of
night school awesome I think coming up
next right here taran killam at taran
killam follow him on twitter in all of
his rams glory i post some ram stuff on
there yeah yeah then I'm seeing it right
horse and nosey on Instagram and and
watch watch a middle you know a man in
his 30s lose his mind that's it that's
the way it goes the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience